ZEDD: I think every little
detail you add into a song
is part of the reason
why you like it so much.
Hey, Anton, what's up, man?
Good, how are you doing?
Hey, welcome to
"One Strange Rock."
Thank you.
There's some really crazy
footage I want you to see.
Come on.
Check it out.
Let's do it.
[music playing]
I am going to tell you about
the most incredible place.
And you know what?
You're walking on it.
You know, so when you're
looking at those images,
I had a chance to see
some of that from space.
And as you go around the
planet, every 90 minutes,
you see a sunrise and a
sunset every 45 minutes.
And you're flying over places
like Afghanistan and Iraq,
places where there's
fighting and wars,
but you don't see any
of that from space.
You just see beauty.
So I've always been a huge
fan of Darren Aronofsky.
I got really excited when I
heard that he was doing this.
What was your experience
working with him?
What he's putting together
now with "One Strange Rock"
is just this visual
palette with all
these different shapes and
colors and sounds and things.
But it's like it takes
you to a whole other level
about learning what
about your planet.
He's brilliant.
So you saw the visual spectrum
of this incredible footage
and planet.
I can't wait to hear
the acoustic spectrum
that you're going to be--
- I can't wait.
--bringing out.
Well, it's really
interesting, because it's
a lot of little things
that make a grand picture.
Right.
Do you sit down in one
take and write the song?
It's a very long process.
I like to start on the
piano with the harmony
and the melody.
That's the base.
And I record it all in MIDI
and bring it into my computer.
And there's several
stages of adding
little bits and pieces, samples,
drums, shakers, experiment.
You go through 200 kicks,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
until you hear that one
that you think is right.
And then you manipulate that.
And you slowly build
your song structure,
and you mix it all together.
And then you bounce
out one little file,
and that's what
people listen to.
[music playing]